>> A CONGRESSWOMAN GOES TO GREA
PAINS PROVING SHE'S GOT NOODLES
FOR BRAINS.
AS YOU SEE A CONGRESSIONAL BULL
KITTEN REJECTING REJECTED FULLY.
ON WEDNESDAY ALSO KNOWN AS THE
DOWN ONE.
>> IT'S A TOUGH COMPETITION BUT
THE SQUAD.
CHALLENGE BANK CEOS TOO STOP
FINANCING FOSSIL FUELS.
HERE SHE IS TRYING TO EXPLAIN
HER POINT.
>> YOU HAVE ALL COMMITTED AS YO
ALL KNOW TO TRANSITION THE
ADMISSIONS AND INVESTMENT
ACTIVITIES TO LINE WITH PATHWAY
TO NET ZERO IN 2050.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
INTERNATIONAL ENERGY AGENCY HAS
SAID IS REQUIRED TO MEET OUR
GOAL ZERO TARGETS A LIMITING
TEMPERATURE RISE TO 2.7 DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT OR 1.5 DEGREES
CELSIUS.
NO NEW FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION
STARTING TODAY SO THAT'S LIKE
ZERO.
>> THAT WAS HARDER TO FOLLOW
THAN A DWARF THROUGH A CORN MAZE
.
YET, I'VE BEEN THERE.
>> THAT'S THE KETTLE CALLING TH
POT BLACK.
I FIGURED YOU'D BE RIGHT BEHIND
HIM.
AND YET HE WANTS EXECS TO ANSWE
SIX SINK LEAD AFTER THAT.
WATCH HOUSE A SINK JC J.P.
MORGAN CEO CAN BE.
>> PLEASE ANSWER WITH A SIMPLE
YES OR NO, DOES YOUR BANK HAVE
POLICY AGAINST FUNDING NEW OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NIGH AND THAT
WOULD BE THE ROAD TO HELL FOR
AMERICA.
HOW'S THAT?
HOW IS THAT FOR A YES OR NO
ANSWER?
THEN SHE CAME UNGLUED FASTER
THAN A BAND-AID IN THE OCEAN.
THAT'S FINE.
EVERY BODY THAT GOT REALLY FROM
STUDENTS HAS A BAKE ACCOUNT WIT
YOUR BANK SHOULD PROBABLY TAKE
OUT THEIR ACCOUNT AND CLOSE
THEIR ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE NOT EVEN THERE TO HELP I
REALLY THAT MANY OTHER FOLKS IN
THAT DEBT BECAUSE OF STUDENT
LOAN AND YOUR OTHER CRITICIZING.
>> WHAT?
THAT WASN'T EVEN THE QUESTION.
IN THIS FOR A CONVERSATION ON A
SUBWAY, WOULD BE SLOWLY BACKING
AWAY FROM HER.
FINALLY, THE LAST AND FINAL
SWING.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU MR.
DIAMOND BECAUSE YOU
OBVIOUSLY DON'T CARE ABOUT
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE LIKE OURS
I'M NOT CAN EVEN ASK IF YOU'RE
COMMITTING TO FINANCING A NEW
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTS.
>> YOU'RE NOT CAN ASK?
THAT WAS YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
WE ARE ALL DUMBER NOW THEM WHEN
I STARTED THIS SEGMENT AND I'M
SORRY FOR BRINGING YOU INTO THIS
.
CAT, WHAT DO YOU MAKE?
DO YOU HAVE ANY ADVICE FOR HER,
BECAUSE THAT CLEARLY WAS A
FAILURE.
>> YEAH.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW A WORD YOU
SHOULD LOOK IT UP.
THE CELL ASSISTS LIKE BECAUSE
EVEN IF HER ARGUMENT WOULD HAVE
MADE SINCE IN OTHER WAYS, SHE
WAS LOST A LOT OF LOST A LOT OF
POINTS FOR SAYING DEGREES
CELSIUS.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU DON'T REALL
THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS BECAUS
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MOVE AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS, WHICH WE DON'T
HAVE YET, YOU NEED AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE INNOVATION IS
POSSIBLE AND THAT IS CAPITALISM.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY IT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE.
DIAMONDS RESPONSE REEKING OF
WHITE PRIVILEGE AND RACISM?
DOESN'T REALIZE YOU SHOULD NOT
BE SPEAKING THAT BLUNTLY IN THA
TRUTH BY LATE TWO MEMBERS OF
SQUAD?
THEY ARE THE OPPRESSED.
>> AT THAT'S WHITE SUPREMACY,
SIGN ME UP.
I MET HIM.
>> WHAT IT IS, WHAT WE HAVE HER
TODAY MY SOUTHERN WHITE, IS WOK
SAY IN TROUBLE BECAUSE THE BIG
COMPANIES AREN'T SCARED NO MORE.
I THINK THAT THING WOKE A LOT O
PEOPLE UP BECAUSE WHAT THE WOKE
DO IS WHEN THEY ASK A QUESTION,
THEY'RE TOO SCARED TO ANSWER.
AND WHAT USUALLY THEY DO IS ASK
OLDER WHITE PEOPLE FEEL BAD AND
WON'T CHALLENGE THEM.
BUT DON MESSED AROUND AND ASKED
AN OLD ENGLISH WHITE WOMEN AND
SHE DID NOT PLAY THAT.
THEN OTHER WHITE PEOPLE SO THAT
SO WHEN SHE ASKED HIM, HE LOOKE
AROUND THE ROOM KNOW THAT STUPID
.
EVERYONE SEES IT BUT THE WOKE
NOW.
WHO ATTACK WAS, I'M GOING TO
TELL PEOPLE THAT THEY GOT THEIR
STUDENT LOANS PAPER TO CANCEL
THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS WILL THAN
THEY WON'T GET THEIR MONEY,.
IT DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE.
SHE'S PROBABLY JUST TO AN
INTERVIEW SITUATIONS LIKE YES O
COURSE THE SALUS IS A PROBLEM.
>> HER HAND WAS ON HER HEART.
SHE'S ARE YOU A RACIST?
>> CAILEE, ANY POINTERS?
>> AT THERE MANY.
FOR THE NEW PRESS SECRETARY.
>> TO BE PURE, THAT WASN'T HALE
TALKING THAT WAS THE BABY.
>> NOT BE BEFORE YOU ATTACKED
THIS YOUNG LADY IT WAS ALL HIM.
IT'S INTERESTING THEY LEFT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW BAD OUR
CANDIDATES ARE ON THE RIGHT.
YOU GUYS HAVE THE SHEET OUT TO
LEAVE AND AOC AND THE HORRIBLE
PEOPLE LIKE RASHIDA SHE USES TH
WORDS OF MEET WITH HOLOCAUST DO
YOU REMEMBER SHE MADE THAT ANTI
SOMATIC STATEMENT?
AND THEN SHE SAID SHE WAS TO
EMPTY THE FEDERAL PRISONS IN TE
YEARS AND MY FAVORITE IS HER
ADVOCACY FOR A NATIONWIDE RENT
MORATORIUM AS SHE IS COLLECTING
32, $100,000 IN RENT.
THESE PEOPLE COULD NOT LIVE UP
TO THEIR OWN HYPOCRISY AND IT T
YOUR POINT NEED DICTIONARIES WA
SHE WAITING THAT OF A
TELEPROMPTER BECAUSE HOW DO YOU
MISPRONOUNCE A WORD UNLESS YOU
NOT READING IT, I DON'T KNOW.
>> I HAVE NEVER GOTTEN THAT.
THE FUNNY THING IS I THINK THAT
SHE KNEW THAT DIAMOND WAS IT
RIGHT.
SHE WANTS IT TO FAIL.
SHE WANTS IT TO ALL GO DOWN THE
TUBES.
>> LET ME SPEAK BROADLY.
SHE IS A VILE, DISGUSTING,
HORRIBLE, ANTI-AMERICAN,
COMMUNIST, AWFUL THE GENERA.
AND I COULD GO ON BUT I WAS
THINKING THIS IS THE NUMBER WHE
SHOWING LATE-NIGHT AND DEAF I
SAID WHAT I REALLY BELIEVE ABOU
HER, YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE
CANCELED.
WHEN I WAS IN THE GREAT ROOM I
ACTUALLY WRITE DOWN WHAT I THIN
ABOUT HER ON A NAPKIN AND I
THOUGHT IT WOULD JUST HAND IT T
YOU AND IF YOU READ THAT ALLOWE
BE BACK IF YOU READ ALOUD I WIL
NEVER BE ON FOX AGAIN.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE SO RICH.
>> I CAN'T DO IT.
PUT IN YOUR POCKET I DON'T THIN
SHE INVESTED EITHER.
>> UP NEXT, AT DISNEY IS NOT IN
YOUR BUDGET, SNEAK